see John Marcin come back right never
tension - oh yeah did you playwright
ever adaption course at pit road
redemption Nikki my Red Dead Revolver
die played written all right
Oh what do you think of four nights
update Oh Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike
you won't think about fortnight come on
took my for night Mike there is a major
videogame conspiracy and I've got the
paper trail to prove it all right Mike
this is the fortnight nobody knows what
the okay Nick I have to stop you there
not only do people know exactly what the
comet is but about 60 million people
across the world have been playing this
update for days where are you getting
all this information I'm getting it from
Tay Eric Tay he's been in the studio all
morning streaming we're talking right
this is the fourth season of updates to
fortnight Battle Royale at the end of
the third season people start seeing
this comma in the sky but now it's a
meteor it has landed in the beginning of
the fourth season what is going on with
this game yes so I think things started
to people started to speculate when we
started seeing telescopes around the map
kind of aiming towards yep right behind
me Amy towards the sky in people on
reddit and everything respecting what
are these telescopes all about and then
you started to see the comet form and it
was really really far away in the sky
and then some people realized that if
you aim towards the comet it would make
a sound and then people took those sound
waves and that made the L dance and this
has kind of been this crazy evolution
and everybody's been speculated
speculating and finally now season four
has begun
[Music]
so the meteor has hit dusty divot and so
that's kind of become the creation of
this new map for seasonal yeah so
there's actually like craters impact
craters across the map right there's a
several but dusty divot is the main one
because it's actually changing the map
which that's kind of cool because you
know battle royale games of the several
that there are now they live and die by
their map at least I think so the fact
that it's actually changed up the map
and create like it's like a social event
right because you can actually go and
get like low gravity or something from
the comet crystals yeah I don't know
basically there's like these consumable
meteor shards and you eat those and it
basically changes gameplay if you do eat
it because you can jump higher you kind
of float here but like in certain
instances like if you have a shotgun you
know you want to be higher up right so
like you know it's easier to aim down
their end-of-season tree leading into
season four it's just been like this
building a pipe and a lot of like theory
crafting which generates a lot of
interest within you know the community
and it's like really cool to see that
happen and we talk all the time like
it's hard to state completely how big
this game is but I do like that they're
introducing story
Entei you were saying earlier it's not
even like story in a traditional sense
it's like how do they fit a story into a
battle royale game or honestly like I
don't think any of us care much about
the narrative but again it's changing
the map which is cool but why are they
putting all this effort into it to make
sure it's like all about like having
care for something and then a purpose
for like an update and so in terms of
for tonight obviously they they kind of
have that campaign mode save the world
whatnot but the more popular mode is
Battle Royale like you said super simple
mode really no need for story but as you
know they add weapons they add new areas
in the map they add all these different
kinds of updates
I think epics thought process was how do
we add these updates and kind of a
narrative flow like a more exciting way
how do we build height to excite players
to like drop in
okay so we want to change the way the
map looks dusty Depot was pretty simple
I guess you could say it was only like
three warehouses how do we change the
the style and the play in that area of
the map I think it's also just because
you're trying to create interest in a
game that people are playing like all
the time a lot right so you have those
frat houses exactly you got to change
some of that dynamic up right so it's
setting a theme for this season and then
starting you know at the end of season
four maybe there's something else that's
gonna happen for season five so it's
like those little subtle changes that
add the extra flavor to the gameplay so
that it doesn't necessarily go stale
because you can play a lot of matches in
Battle Royale
right and you kind of get sick and tired
of seeing the same thing especially for
light yeah exactly and so like it's cool
for the community to be able to like
find the villains hideout now that there
is a villains hideout and like you know
there's the hero mansion which a lot of
people are saying like it's like the
x-men mansion there's all these little
spots even though it's the same map that
they found ways to still create
interests and create that kind of
surprise for the fans to fly the way
they're building this like pseudo
narrative around it's such a massive
game and we've talked about before like
I wasn't caught on for tonight at the
beginning especially save the world I
wasn't like really into fort night
Battle Royale but every choice they make
as far as like the Hivites they do like
seem to like kick-ass now they're doing
this story and again like Rob was saying
earlier so much of this game seems to be
word-of-mouth and like this is only
gonna help that it's a social event it's
like this phenomenon
stuff like this like oh [ __ ] you see
like dusty depots gone now like tilt the
towers like what if that gets hit by
another meteor like people are talking
about like I hate this part of the map
you need to destroy that and like you
said disregarding savage the newest map
and pub G pretty much every match before
night it's gonna be fast at about G
match so you're right you're going
through these repetitions of the map
more and more often each time you play
and this is like seems only good as far
as like making it dynamic I guess to
sound kind of reductive but it seems
like they are doing no wrong epics part
and this team I think it's also a really
really good business move for epic too
because by creating that hype maybe
people who didn't get to participate in
season 3 now know that there are limited
time skins so there are superhero skins
for season 4 yeah
those who really want to grind and earn
those skins there's more incentive to
buy a battle pass and like earn those
rewards and I think that the the theming
and like creating this kind of like
sci-fi superhero theme for season 4 it's
like the perfect time if you're a player
maybe you haven't bought a battle pass
in the past boom this might be your
incentive to like jump in so I think
it's a perfect business move in terms of
epic business yeah it seems like it's
just like another in a long line of good
decisions on ethics part once this blew
up but having said that Nick I will let
you clean up this disaster
[Laughter]